from the intriguing and mysterious plot
the soundtrack boozing with 80s bangers
and Winona Ryder's incredible turn as
Joyce buyers there's a lot to love about
the new Netflix original series stranger
things for my money it does an excellent
job of referencing cult 80 sci-fi
without it becoming completely
overbearing if you like stranger things
and are looking for something with a
similar flavor here's a few of its key
influences these are all well worth
checking out if you haven't seen or read
them already but if you haven't seen the
show then don't worry
spoilers are gonna be kept to an
absolute minimum because you seriously
need to delve into that mystery as fresh
as possible let's kick off with a fairly
obvious one as the show is basically a
giant omage to Stephen King's work even
down to the logo so naturally Steve is
absolutely loving it King excels in
telling stories about the ordinary
meeting the extraordinary usually
involving small town locals coming up
against improbable and surreal
situations not unlike the citizens of
Hawking's Indiana who get embroiled in a
missing-child case come up against
psychic powers a sinister government
agency and some kind of world ending
evil but with so many King books to read
which of his novels have influenced
stranger things the most well the misfit
bullied kids who seem to be targeted by
a powerful otherworldly enemy is taken
right out of it yes this is the one with
the terrifying clown monster but it's
also a story about friendship and
adorable kids working together to take
on the ultimate evil stranger things
really kicks off when some dark entity
escapes from the halkans National
Laboratory and out into the town this
motif has been explored in multiple King
novels such as the stand which in my
opinion is his magnum opus
it's where the US Army scientists create
a weaponized strain of flu only to be
completely unprepared for when it
inevitably escapes destroying something
like 99% of the world's population the
character of L in the show is a direct
parallel to Charlie McGee from the novel
firestarter both a young girls with
unnatural psychic powers but where L
lived a life of captivity
and was experimented upon at the Hawkins
National Lab Charlie's powers were a
result of government experimentation on
her parents her family ends up on the
run from a government agency known as
the shop who are determined to track
Charlie down to use her powers as a
weapon
just like Elle you could also compare
Elle to Carrie White from Kings first
novel Carrie which also follows a young
girl as she struggles to come to terms
with her new psychic powers all the
Stephen King books I just talked about
have film adaptations of varying degrees
of quality I'd maybe give firestarter
and the 2013 Carrie remake a Miss but
there are other movies that have really
inspired stranger things there's a lot
of spielberg in there like ET the
extra-terrestrial following kids who
befriend a strange and mysterious alien
while trying to keep it hidden from
grownups and of course the government
who just want to run experiments on it
whereas in the show it's Mike and his
friends trying to keep L safe
there's also Close Encounters of the
Third Kind an average guy has a close
encounter but no one believes him very
similar to how no one believes all the
weird stuff that Joyce and Hopper
discover and think that they've gone a
little bit crazy instead and if you like
the motif of nerdy kids banding together
to solve crimes and uncover mysteries
and go on adventures together there is
of course the Goonies and Stand By Me
The Goonies features loads of typical
80s character stereotypes the gang of
misfit kids the outcasts older brother
the sensible salt of the earth best
friends all of who we can see in some
form or another in stranger things in
Stand By Me which is also an adaptation
of a Stephen King novella boy did the
stranger things guys love Stephen King
there's a strong friendship group made
up of four boys you go on one last
adventure together to try and find the
body of a missing boy they tell each
other stories and jokes and have a
special handshake and are basically the
strong friendship group who go through
ups and downs together just like Mike
Lukas dust in and of course will do and
of course this cult TV shows that have a
huge influence on stranger things like
The Twilight Zone and the short-lived
Outer Limits who are both filled with
lingering dread
Bend's and psychological horror we are
controlling transmission if we wish to
make it louder
we will bring up the button
if we wish to make it softer we will
tune it to a whisper all of which
stranger things has in spades Twin Peaks
is another there's plenty of parallels
to draw
Special Agent Dale Cooper investigates
the murder of homecoming queen Laura
Palmer is small in Sela town similarly
chief hopper gets dragged into a series
of mysteries in a small insular town
that all begin with young will fires
going missing so there's a few cult
inspirations for stranger things I'm
sure to have missed some I mean there
was loads to choose from so let me know
your favorites in the comments below for
more on strange things make sure you
like the video and subscribe to
youtube.com / GameSpot and we will see
you next time
you